mind your decisions I'm presto Walker
rectangle ABCD is divided into smaller
rectangles all of the dimensions in this
diagram are given in centimeters and the
diagram is not drawn to scale the shaded
rectangle has an area of nine square
centimeters find the area of rectangle
ABCD pause the video if you'd like to
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching to learn how to
solve this problem
[Music]
we'll get started by focusing on the
dimensions of the shaded rectangle we
then calculate the area of this
rectangle
it'll be y multiplied by the quantity Y
minus 8 this is equal to 9 square
centimeters we then distribute the Y
term and subtract 9 from both sides we
factor the quadratic equation and we get
two potential solutions y is equal to 9
and Y is equal to negative 1
since we're dealing with lengths we want
a positive value so we retain Y is equal
to 9 we then calculate the length of AD
it'll be equal to 1 plus 11 the total
length will be equal to 12 and that's
the length of BC because opposite sides
in a rectangle have the same length we
then have X is equal to 12 the length of
a B is equal to X minus 4 which means AV
is equal to 8 so it seems like we can
calculate the area of ABCD as follows
it's equal to 8 times 12 which is equal
to 96 square centimeters this would seem
to be the answer but it's not correct go
back to the original diagram and notice
that a portion of CD is equal to Y which
means a portion of CD is equal to 9 so
we have a very strange shape the entire
length of a B is equal to 8 but its
opposite side which is supposed to be
equal to 8 has a portion which is equal
to 9 in other words we have a portion of
a side being longer than the site itself
so the actual answer is we cannot
calculate the area of ABCD
because the dimensions in this problem
are impossible after the test was given
they did admit this was an error in the
exam personally I'm not opposed to trick
questions once in a while because it
keeps students on guard from broght
calculations so always be careful if the
dimensions actually make any sense
thanks for making mind your decisions
one of the best channel
on YouTube as always thanks for watching
and thanks for your support
[Music]
[Music]